[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
dati site super h 30 avec moins d'hommes
plantes semaine au podcast on a reçu des
personnalités de créateurs de contenu
cam grande brune et fred bastien premier
podcast officiellement à 4,10 par le fun
on est vraiment ça on a parlé de progrès
un sujet encore une fois un podcast très
dense mais très intéressant politique
explorations spatiales intelligence
artificielle sexualité santé mentale on
touche vraiment après laffaire
mais ont eu beaucoup de plaisir j'espère
que d'autres soucis si vous aimez le
sans-fil podcast la meilleure façon nous
encourager c'est d'aller voir la page
pétri en honneur du contenu exclusif
latu des podcasts exclusive des clones
excuses excusez vous allez même pouvoir
poser vos questions aux invités la page
pétulante c'est dans la gestion de la
vidéo allez voir ça c'est vraiment la
meilleure façon de les encourager
comme d'habitude inscrivez-vous à la
chaîne juste un beau ici et suivez nous
sur les podcasts ou les mardis da site
bon écoute pour podcast
[Musique]
camille bonjour salut merci d'être
premier en fête premier podcast depuis
le premier mois est ce qu'on n'est qu'à
sept fois dans la cale micro la nappe en
avait trop micro pour quatre ans le fait
que le siat micro officiel c'est là le
gros les gros équipage les les grands
lacs et le lac des podcasts et laquelle
l'activité ou c'est juste la carrosserie
sans moteur série two way premièrement
première fois qu'on s'est vus c'est
tellement plus oui elle de toute ma vie
au jeu non seulement si oui à la base
la première vue c'est sur le plateau
d'on déplaçant des gens morts de
l'intérieur pourquoi 126 qui ces gens là
le jeu tenus sur l'occupation de hockey
on pourrait appeler ce so you think you
grow que vous le saviez pas existé au de
plus ben on savait que ça existait on
avait déjà une idée s'était coiffée 15e
temps vélo puis j'ai réalisé que témoin
je me dis que ce n'est pas la finale en
plus c'est fini que trop minutes d'un
match entre
ça n'a pas fait l'unanimité tout à fait
mais c'est le fun c'est la seule fois
que j'ai assisté à l'émission je t'ai
pas vu la prochaine on savait pas on me
disait c'est sûrement juste un talk show
est ce que c'est mais c'est avec un ton
neutre deming oui c'est assez fou je
t'ai vu aussi pour tel un beau t-shirt à
face chez nous car tournis chine ressort
à bord c'est pas parce que des dépôts le
fonds disponibles pour ni en fait ni
chaud à la main avec ta face dessus puis
c'est moi qu'ils pourquoi la nuit
oui parce que c'est un one photo mais
oui c'est je t'avais n'ont mené que j'y
parle mais c'est l'occasion rêvée de le
montrer mais la longue histoire cosmo
est une grande fan d'occupation de là
bas si tu étais de préférer un certain
point d'en manquer avec adam commens est
grosse a 20 qui décide de montrer adamo
les boutiques étaient drômois ce soir
mais oui mais oui mais oui parce qu'on
peut le dire c'est vraiment vraiment il
est drôle depuis le jour mais fac bref
pas mal je faisais l'émission c'est
juste du bon dit comme invités puis à
nous apporter un cadeau à l'équipe piano
de nagy s'ils sont bons vous dit marie
curie j'ai acheté après j'étais jaloux
oui parce que moi que j'avais affirmé
ploie bros toi mon aventure à me faire
un dessin à la main de tafas sur un tee
shirt un de ses buts la vraie histoire
désagréable raconte tout comme soliste
un vieux t-shirt qui ya comme une tache
de la rejeter juillet un méga scène john
mann sous des bâches ou des bruits mais
mes données mais les cannois parfait
pour même envisagé avec ses chalets la
pensée assez juste web les porteurs
n'ont pu donc je me déguise pas unique
le carré bleu toute cette jeunesse à
face à sa fin si je me souviens plus et
là avec toutes les faces message et je
savoure sa tour je suis comme je suis
choquée fournit pas que ça bouchonne
certainement mais oui c'est fou à la
petite boutique avec un talent bien
tarzan piqué gc ms ta poche comme modèle
ça fait ça fait longtemps que personne
n'a pas ça nous fait du bien car un
arrêté de m'en parler qu'un nouveau
commencer aujourd'hui
ouais si soyons tout nouveau monde puis
chez nous autant plus dans mon cercle
comme rapprochés on connaissait bien le
livre fait que le monde se sont comme
commencé à s'acharner sur
traquer le moins bon qu'à la pause bong
pour des jo c'est pour te rapprocher de
toi que sous tes amis oui ou le monde a
invité comme ça m'arrive avant
j'ai fait de la télé réalité à
musiqueplus c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé ma carrière en 2002 je fais du
budget le chercheur
c'est autrement - oui que vous a bien
eus
il ya eu 1 1 sochaux modes de jeu de
plus pour manifester car nick et moi on
est en danger parce qu'ils ont ramassé
les deux maîtres fax et nous cela fait
une semaine qu'on est emprisonné
la semaine on avait la chance de voir
les épisodes mais c'est sûr que ça doit
être cinq fois plus fréquents chez vous
mais moi j'avais déjà quand même pas mal
le monde times mary piqué sauvaient
c'est pour être belle
juste comme ça demeure de le prendre
c'est comme j'avais vraiment pas le goût
aux gens réclament à cette personne
c'est ça de quelconque référence à l'eau
pour se rapprocher de moi je fais des
genres ont été moins prétentieux quant à
nabil attaquant est le plus souvent
joachim s'est aussi fait des roses
pillet c'est ce que le montage accentué
sa com ont bien été les mots c'est
beaucoup c'est aussi que je voyais qu'il
est il exagéré un sous officier comme ça
c'est ce monde à la barre des rivalités
drôle de forme mais comme je voyais ça
comptait québec
ben moi je sais pas comment c'est perçu
ce cas c'est perçu comme en avant comme
moi et moi je pense que j'ai
communication fait c'est vraiment un
couloir puis j'ai fait les jeux de la
communication puis comme je dis j'ai
plein d'amis n'en veut maintenant
l'université laval que j'ai rencontrés
encore des jeux de la communication mais
un une meilleure lisibilité du cam la
vallée jeu là comme si ça a longtemps
été les deux mains d'une veste en
communications au québec en a plusieurs
qui ont rattrapé quand même c'est sûr
que moi je continue d'être le micro à
campi laval aussi mais peu de l'uqam de
longs mois et non sept comme au québec
de communication quand même le parce que
sur d'autres domaines
autre chose mais donc c'est tribal
taylor fait que beaucoup de monde qui
haïssez l'uqam parce que ben il sait
très contingentés fait que ça se peut
que la peau était bien le cas la vaste
et les mighty ducks parce que c'était
ceux qui avaient une chance de battre
l'uqam pauvres et le pauvre et
d'activités comme les norvégiens
comme chaque année les landes étaient
ceux qui avaient une chance de nous
battre ce qui était vraiment bon pied
face à cris des gens de frictions mais
mais c'est comme dans le sport
les équipes 2 go qui vont finir par être
body parce qu'on est un exemple et je la
communication c'est vraiment intéressant
c'est très pertinent pour les
professionnels mais c'est aussi un méga
portée puis déclare des routiers des
drôles de raconter des drôles de
tradition puis par exemple au début des
jeux de la communication même s'il ya
des précieuses sont bien espèce de
paradis où le monde sont déguisés dans
les glissements de l'oranie petit le
monde dames seules applaudissent les
autres pistes et les gens donnent du
spirit puis un espèce est maintenant
reportée sinon ils vont lancer des
bombes ont gâché la balle arrive déguisé
ou déguisé en barrage criminelle en
faisant rien les remettre en jambes du
heavy métal pierre faisant défaut qui
nous a tous bords à la com littéralement
ce genre ces copies ce que parce qu'on
lui connaît comme étant sous qui se
réapproprient ce genre de personne
gas mc c'est sûr qu'on est comme moi
sont un peu battre et en argent au site
émotion c'est quoi je prends mon petit
acte et je sais aussi c'est quoi la
regarde comme de jeter canabier soit
lavallois non mais écoutez je le prends
et je le prends bien cesser il me faut
montrer quelque chose qui était pas
exaucé pour juste magnifique ce look cas
mais non mais je voudrais commencer par
la dernière fois que je vous ai vu les
deux à la fois qu'on s'est vus c'était
pour le mac and cheese qu'on a fait
ensemble puis depuis ce temps là le
match et c'est probablement ce qu'on
m'envoie le plus
ah ouais est ce que tu leur fais 1 go to
oui je les fais ouais ouais c'est fou ce
que tu as envie de refaire un autre
temps avec tout le livre de réussite on
se fait envoyer vraiment beaucoup d'un
certain historique ça c'est le fun de
savoir que le monde fonce hull puis qui
que ce soit le mackenzie c'est vraiment
le big one hell de toute la gang est
vraiment cool je fais pas souvent mais
une faute en sortant je suis dit
capsules de bouffer et le nombre de fois
que les gens et à gandhi stories
propager la bonne nouvelle
récemment j'ai autorisé j'avais j'avais
partagé ma sauce à spag vg il a personne
ça fait deux ans qu'il a fait mais ouais
mais c'est sur un black et ce qu'ils
puissent qui s'occupent pas là c'est ce
qui est le plus malade des boeufs
en plus le tout ces gens mais c'est que
c'est c'est directement en fait capoter
moi je pus tard et fait c'est juste du
web
ou est-ce que tu parlais de nous qu'elle
connaît de sortie d'audi on a fait celui
avec camille douay ce qu'on faisait de
l'auto exact je me disais tu disais je
pense que tu je pense que c'était judith
et qui je dise quelque chose que tu
disais rien mais tu es ph me fait penser
un peu à moi quand je suis devenu vg il
était comme le papy-boom maintenant au
début du catch de se jeter comme et
qu'est ce qui veut dire qu'il a
maintenant je comprends ce que tu
l'exercice
parce que moi aussi je te bourrer bavure
mais qu'est ce que je dis assez cool ce
qu'ils font aux médecins on pourrait se
passer du thon paternité c'est enfin pu
très apprécié des petits ph ça fait deux
mois que tvg viens pas me donner des
conseils l'été puis en définitive
je me suis vraiment plus sauf mon
approche que quand je suis devenu que
c'est ce qu'il voulait dire oui pierre
aussi je joue aussi je donne un coup de
main à 100 sous une des raisons qu'on
est plus intense qu'on commence c'est
pas juste à cause qu'on vient de
commencer
tout le monde sait pas si le cas pour
tous étaient plus à la mode quand a
commencé moi j'habite certains et à
montréal jeter les goûts victoria
première mais peut-être aussi de creuser
une fée ou jean jégou et mangé un steak
c'est un peu comme aujourd'hui encore
plus c'est que au début tout le monde en
parle tout le temps ces salles a
carrément donné ta gueule tous attendus
aussi la désarmante le gâte quand vient
le temps de parler t'es qu'un baume tu
exploses parce que ça fait huit mois que
jean papa maman sylvie les cousins
tomber un remix aucun des buts mais avec
la terre l'homme est végétarien que le
monde sait aussi l'inversé les jeunes
banc - bâtisse passées comme celles que
je m'en parler moins et parce que je me
rappelle quand on a commencé à sortir
ensemble
il ya des amis que ça faisait longtemps
que j'étais ami avec manu on allait
manger
il faisait 1 tv était ami avec tout
depuis longtemps oui mais maintenant le
monde qui est j'ai rencontré à haute
vitesse qui mange pas avec moi la
famille mais vous savez vous on a mangé
ensemble qui savent même pas que j'ai
commandé la vg parce que effectivement
je fais pas chier mais à l'époque c'est
juste que le monde qui te connais il
voit la transition fax exerce ces femmes
défendre défendre devant tout le témoin
d'un monde à mon poste est sûr c'est que
les sorties nous on avait des suspects
entre amis puis c'est pas moi qui en
parlent mais sincèrement tisse peu mais
une fois normand par louis jean bart
c'est embêtant pour lui qui a amené le
sujet au début c'est le petit informe le
plus ou si c'est comme si l'attentât est
plutôt le goût d'en parler
comme n'importe quoi tu apprends de
nouveau au dessus ça devient l'enfer je
suis aussi un peu plus soft dans le sens
où ça fait 12 ans que je suis là depuis
au moins huit ans où j'ai pas mangé de
poisson les gens mangent du poisson ne
perdrait 4
mais c'est quand même assez les curés je
suis pas vigueur non plus tu es je mange
des jugements chômage et celle des
pauvres il faut avec ce n'est pas
parfait mais mon point le suivant c'est
qu'il y aurait un parfait non plus pis
ma vie est installé tout se complique et
d'adopter un régime de vie gay nasa pour
scène pour un paquet de facteurs
incluent à la mobilité mais donc
peut-être qu'un jour je me rapprocher de
la perfection ce mécanisme 10h23 -
travailler pour un pas mais aucun sens
avait 35 ans
ce qui s'en vient parce que si je
comprends et j'en ai parlé récemment sur
instagram je pense avant on avait juste
qu'il faisait déjà face au jugement je
fasse tout pour faire une envie mais les
menus des restaurants il ya toujours au
moins 3,4 dans les restaurants le chef
débarque il y avait fait faux
et puis je suis le seul à l'avoir fait
pis y'a plein de végétariens qu'ils font
de puteaux qui sont battus c'est
vraiment plus soft que dans les droits
humains sauf que c'est vrai sassou c'est
tellement plus facile pour les gens la
nouvelle vague maintenant parce qu'ils
ont honte de me fâcher mais par des
jeunes victimes de césaire gens qui sont
comme aujourd'hui jusqu'à l'os a fait
douze ans que chauffe des boeufs qui
tout est à son quatrième haute et plus
intense que moi c'est cher mais ça fait
douze ex show débute donc au moins c'est
tellement plus facile pour tous
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai on a amené
marché a d'abord demandé des solutions
l'hôpital est à ce projet chaque petit
geste compte
une journée que tu mange pas de viande
cette journée-là par semaine
je trouve cette magie mais là on est 9
milliards la planète 9 6 mais si tout le
monde mais tant qu'on y est 8
pour être au milieu c'est tout le monde
mange vg
une fois par semaine c'est comme uts
milliards c'est comme un milliard de vg
par semaine dont les perdants dans le
monde en fait ce qui est déjà un impact
personne sur sept
le tas de tâches à tout le monde qu'ils
sont complètement l'essai c'est ce que
j'ai lu les semaines passent et que si
au moment où on se parle 90% des humains
moore est instantanément qu'ils y
resteraient quand même plus de monde sa
planète que les années 1700
sauf si grave maintenant pendant des
milliers d'années comme un million de
milliards qui a explosé on essaie
d'aller contre d'autres présentement
mais je pense que c'est une fièvre
c'est comme ceux qui s'essaient les
prochains défis parce qu'il ya des
places qui vont se faire complètement
wipe et j'aime les sa méfiance est donc
extrêmement important d'où ils exagèrent
midi la planète et l avant c'est toi qui
vas mourir lui avait prescrit sa planète
saisir fait savoir pham et on sera
peut-être plus de ses courbes à craquer
aussi c'est thriller moi je vais plus
loin c'est tout est composé des cellules
qui sont vivantes décès le condamnant
qu'à lyon au noyau donc un cerveau
irrespect piment au jeu qu'ils puissent
ils font partie de quoi de plus gros que
pi i donc ils sont invités peut-être qui
on sait pas mais une conscience une tête
qui contraint de pau l'ordre de grandeur
d'âme dans un vaisseau sanguin d'être
danseuse nue mais que nous on joue à
mario kart mais tant pis si oui peuvent
pas comprendre mais presse conjoint
mario bros est bon ce qui s'appelait
marcel là jusque ici pour jouer sur
toujours pas d'enfant c'est tout
mais non mais c'est aussi l'autre
conversation un peu plate c'est que ça
fait partie des pistes de solution je
pense pour réussir à ramener la
population un nouveau contrôleur sur
terre parce que men à la répartition des
ressources est déjà déficiente c'est
quand on pourrait nourrir tout le monde
si on était du sport sous la main mais
meyer beaucoup de négatif
beaucoup de monde dans le monde pitti
immagine toi tout bon vin chaud on est
qui nous pour dire aux chinois pour
l'afrique
le problème c'est de baisser un peu le
nombre d'humains pour qu'on peut se
mesurer à passer les ressources qui
continue de faire de l'exploration
spatiale et de l'or qui s'assoupit mario
cuomo cité trois raisons d'être de
l'exploration spatiale et l'or là sont
les raisons consolidation la nation je
pense exploration explorations mais je
pense que c'est ce qu'on peut faire des
attaques limitées on est rendu à
l'époque où on a tellement propre
religion qui disent que je viens
d'écrire le sais que mon mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait d'abord connaître
nous continuons d'être un virus mais
comme prenons soin les organismes
comparer comparé à l'iss parce que
l'idée de la cellule que je te dis
qu'ils aient beaucoup rien qui aimable
le plus gros organismes mais c'est la
même chose pour les humains de la
planète à rennes où on est dans le coup
de plus gros l'atmo imagine que la
planète évident à penser à un noyau à le
désarmer respect peut-être qu'à mange
aussi le jeu pour goran maric la
décomposition et que j'en attendais
conçoit des infrastructures peut-être
que l'internet c'est le système nerveux
de la planète qui est le futur c'est que
tous les humains sont employés sur 1 ap
ap la mairie
nous autres on écoute beaucoup de
joueurs organe n'est pas de casse sur
les bad et le must
mais justement sur le podcast dylan
masquer le monde ont vu le mine parce
qu'à 15 juin mais la réalité c'est
quelqu'un comme puff élections
pirate est légal bien l'enseignement ou
est-ce qui parle justement de de
l'informatique de commandes
l'intelligence artificielle va
éventuellement prendre le contrôle d'une
mosquée quand même il refuse de se
prononcer de ça va peut-être être cool
37 être la pire chose qui va arriver à
l'humanité ce qui donne un exemple puis
ça mais ça m'a marqué beaucoup je
courrai plus écouté sur piles il dit
imaginez votre thé et john games entier
comment tu peux décrire mettons
l'intelligence artificielle parce que
lui ce qu'ils disent qu'on ne peut pas
assez de 22,8 pour intégrer
l'information qu'il assure une vitesse
assez élevé mais qui dit imaginez votre
cellulaire dans votre main et vous avez
accès à toute l'information en faisant
des jt en écrivant maintenant sur google
lui dis ce que ça peut devenir c'est
qu'on se bloque dans quelque chose
puis tout ça on le sait une question de
la réponse chez toi quel point tu peux
aller vite mais ça doit pour il conserve
aussi mais il travaille je sais pas ce
qu'ils font mais c'est une compagnie d'
et de mosquées comme l'objectif c'est de
john wayne
les orties les serbes ou exact le plus
cher du monde chez bt comme base dr un
biocide et les gens calmes et boul
non mais lui lui vraiment ludique et
quand même 10 niveaux catégorie bosque
si jacky corbier répondit l'humain mais
là c'est moi le super héros ou le super
vilain mais comme le bon gars mais train
ou non
comme ce 17e la paix ou la même chose
pour exact puis lui hacker qui a une
approche qui me
ça m'intéressait dit que l'oeil a décidé
d'arrêter d'être pessimiste parce que
c'était un gars vraiment pessimiste
puis voyez l'avenir la terre puis il
était vraiment pessimiste pitié des
sacrements ça on s'en sort pas de celle
de l'éthique
pizzi mais au final que ça va me faire
là ma vie d'être pessimiste exact
à quoi ça va ça vient des primes et
transgressif pépite depuis aucune raison
et imagine si toi dans ta tête
la finalité est dingue 30 ans oui mais
bon est-ce que tu fait jusque là
dans trente ans a fini pourquoi tu te
lèves le matin c'est lui lui de toute
personne sur la terre célébrant la
personne qui sème le matin je veux
sauver l'humanité pas grand monde sa
planète qui se dessine et pilier
j'aimerais que ce soit l'eau puis dessus
pose la question est-ce que c'est légal
mais en fait je lui mettais lui
l'objectif l'était il ya une sorte de
compagnie mais c'est l'objectif promis
qu'ils qu'il me laissait mars
c'est lui c'est le matin c'est bon comme
en conserva sur mars avec la compagnie
s'appelle 6 qui réussissent c'est la
nasa l'ancien satellite outil est allé
dans l'espace ce que ça demandait
c'était des coups vraiment trop
exorbitant pour que ce soit utile de lui
russie en ayant tout bon prix a
travaillé vingt heures par semaine pour
des pinottes puis en trouvant des moyens
de leurs chaînes satellites pour une
fraction du prix
et puis pour faire aller dans l'espace
bessy dit aussi longtemps que ça vous
coûter 10 millions lors d'une fusée on
voyait jamais aussi longtemps que les
fusées sont plus utilisables vécu cette
nuit là dessus juste avant de créer une
fusée qui peuvent y en a une je te
manière atterri
latry tesla ces maladies sont démentes
et des trucs qui se déplace avec dû se
déplace dans l'espace avec du de
l'extincteur à moteur parce que tu as
besoin de sigean ton avion dans l'espace
peut déplacer avec juste parce que
tellement pas de résistance en gaspiller
pour te déplaces l'accélération sais que
tu accélères d'une façon constante sur
le temps trop faire parler ses textes
façon constante finir sur ce bon exemple
mais ton super six qui réussi à
descendre le prix du voyage dans
l'espace qui joue que sur un bon exemple
de compagnie de du marché privé qui
n'utilisaient pas ce que c'est comment
un partenariat public-privé nasa sur
l'amazone et gouvernementales du v6 et
privés et mes défauts le privé pour
réussir à mener les cours à la baisse
qui est toutefois il peut donner un méga
coup de main à des incitatifs
gouvernementaux comme base à se rendre
plus loin et c'est donc faux contre les
gouvernements continuent à dépenser de
l'argent et recherche puis un en asie
d'ici là jean spatiale canadienne
au canada six grecs mais c'est cool
multimillionnaire qui met you know what
moi je peux me servir de ma capacité à
être ultra capitaliste pour faire le
bien ce niveau le démocrate il voyage
spatial à toutes les agents certains oui
matin un vol bientôt plus d'ailleurs
si vous voulez de chaque mois de salaire
dans la zone de fouet il ce soir c'est
la fin d'une période d'inscription se
montre ce que moche sur ce malade de la
nasa mais jouer qu'avec d'autres
québécois qui en est d'autres créateurs
de contenu ça pourrait vous que les à
vous parce que les choses votre déjà
sorti mais il yad'autres sur d'autres 14
bookeen qui nous écoutent allez voir le
site nasa sochaux qui cessa à lorient 1
0 et 3 à sochaux puis invite des
personnalités social comme comme nous le
suggère des médias numériques juste que
tu saches bien novembre exactement sur
700 applications à 120,30 maintenant ils
m'ont ils m'ont retenu type au point ce
que ce soir c'est la fin d'une baisse
d'inscriptions pour le décollage space x
avec la nasa pour la personne comme
bientôt lui 2019 mais dans le premier on
le voit peu mais il réunit des gens de
partout dans le monde qui ont des
tribuns des réseaux sociaux
mais de fait du climat ton il y avait un
gars qui fait du yoga ya bien des
danseuses de justin bieber qu un million
d'abonnés qui fait le jeu de danse moue
devant les appareils lamazou un modèle à
l'espace ses coûts c'est fou on a eu
plus de respect des gens le directeur la
nasa des gens le poste scientifiques qui
disent cabinet place au québec parce que
tous les ennemis si atypique s'adresse à
tous les catholiques midi et merci des
bleus sans vous on n'est rien parce que
119 woodside schild la fiancée palabrer
science avant qu'elles soient partagées
puis c'est vrai qu'ensuite pense pas où
ils désirent des années a comme trouver
mais je vous encourage à la fois c'est
que c'est hyper côté dépenses mais il
trouve les portes
si amazon mais des personnes accroupies
les îles donc intelligent lancement
d'une mosquée explique ce qui se passe
une collaboration avec la nasa un homme
que le doute le certifie que ça
ressemblait n'ont jamais cessé se casse
une décision consciente qu'on fait les
libéraux c'est moderne c'est une manière
de réfléchir aux un niveau assez beau
les enjeux
éthique de notre ère et pour ceux qui
mettent à nu
mais jean tanneau ski gens qui voyaient
pas l'espace ya trop de monde ça plein
air c'est la suisse qui ont dit ça
revient ce qu'on disait tantôt qu'est ce
qu'on fait je trouve que moi me suis pas
un fan de films de super-héros
nécessairement mais le meilleur film bd
que j'ai vu pour ce domaine là la bd
pipi les pilotes film les deux je trouve
que c'est des oeuvres incroyable puis
ses droits parce que la fin des deux
noms mais je dirais pas mais c'est juste
que les différentes mais tu affrontes
est ce un mécha qui prend les décisions
mais pour le bien commun un médecin mais
pas les le médecin réflexion parce que
c'est vraiment plus complexe que je suis
un méchant qui y vais peut-être la
fiction permet ça va maintenant on le
sait c'est possible d'imaginer un futur
où est ce que le sait pas qui on
abandonne la terre puis on embarque x
dans une navette vers ces cas ne trouve
que sauf que c'est possible d'imaginer
un monde parce que c'est ce qui arrive
c'est un mannequin annoncé se met à mon
goût c'est quelqu'un qui doit prendre la
décision
lille hockey olive d'avis
des scientifiques québécois québécoise à
la nasa aura des rencontres i gr 2
filles qui parlent français qui vient du
québec travaille à la maison d'en face
moi je vis dans un monde où peut-être
qu'un jour on pourrait appeler ça tel le
tram à nos fins
c'est comme parce que si on continue
d'avoir un impact sur l'industrie
aérospatiale mondiale au québec mais on
voit mal classé niveau 2 pour des
romanov à force et non de tel à année
parce que l'on parle d'eux dans une
galaxie c'est fou c'est une référence
que même pour habiller tout casser je
connais même s'ils n'ont ici tellement
bons essais même si c'était drôle même
si c'était un peu niaiseux c'était
tellement bien je trouve que c'est un
produit juste de storytelling
d'émanations incroyable en plus a ouvert
l'esprit de plaintes québécois sur
l'espace donc peut-être que sans lien
avec lui vers ce qu'on a à voir mais qui
veut tourner trop très créatif en
général lee franco canadien
je parle de jets plus tout le monde là
dedans je connais bien mais on a écouté
[Rires]
mais mais non mais émet donc ça prend la
créativité pour aller dans l'espace
donc peut-être que jonas holos nombreux
quelque chose de fort pour nous tous
honnêtement c'est quelque chose qui est
que gens que je trouve très envisageable
oui vite c est eux raconte qu'elle
invite peut la changer ce qui existe
entre est clos
les entreprises ayant vraiment nommé
un score vraiment nommé quelque chose
c'est dans l'espace lundi pour twitter
david saint-jacques de faire un job
portes de l'espace le québec explose
surtout à leur taille et tout le monde
l'agent spatial canadien rim à ce
maillot il connaît 10la du porte de
garage
[Rires]
monsieur monsieur
chris hadfield du porte de garage mais
moi je préfère les romanov a pour
l'instant c'est encore plus épique
savait plus récent quart d'heure a tout
récemment les comme quoi les
météorologues et les ovnis brisé il
brise
il sait comme pas une batterie peu
d'équipement qui peuvent pas les
récupérer parce que ça coûte trop cher à
les récupérer
i dans le fond est ce qu'ils annoncent
la météo brise la météo il sa brise la
couche d'ozone
en fait c'est que ça tombe la plus
économique d'aller dans l'espace un
ballon c'est parce que ça peut monter un
fou mais on n'y a plus de match par
métier la pression interne du ballon
fuse le carton pitt et quentin typique
où trouver la récupérer parce que
l'équipe intéressant pour le récupérer
mais c'est assez complexe
la musique a pris la place tahrir un
atelier de donc mais ils n'ont pas
mentionné que des fois on les trouvait
pas parce que eux comme la mission était
de récupérer l'instrument hfi de
tchéquie ce qui avait capté ou chez
beaucoup émission ait pas de
récupération le début oui comme moi
j'avoue que c'est d'avoir beaucoup le
monde
mon seul et à chaque jour ouais ouais
chaque jour ça prendrait la pression 1
qui clôt pascal ce oui c'est des kilos
pareil ça fait longtemps que je fais de
la saq les pattes au genre il ya
d'autant ajouté
mais j'aime serait
mais j'aime ça parlait de tuer puis
surtout avec vous parce que je voulais
je voulais mentionner ce le fait que
vous êtes des créateurs de contenu qui
parle des sujets qui moi m'importe
beaucoup c'est pas le cas de beaucoup de
créateurs de contenu puis ce je vous
lève mon chapeau parce que vous traiter
des sujets qui sont vraiment porte à
réflexion
vous n'êtes pas du divertissement
gratuit les six des dix sujets que des
combattants le ti cats idylle
géopolitique vraiment inquiets qui me
fait triper s'écoule way qui rapport à
la sexualité
je suis déménagé il ya 10 ans à montréal
pour étudiants c'est une vidéo
mais c'est quelque chose qui me
passionne vraiment beaucoup je pense
qu'on en parle pas assez
m mais alors l'exploration se passe au
maroc je pense qu'elle est mais n'ont
aucun espoir est auteur / tu as
cherbourg donne à peu près tout l'espace
en fait on quand mes gars avec jesse ses
revenus est revenu le soir et après
avoir tout de suite le préfet le maire
comme fait son coming out francella le
chef ouais c'est que les gens vraiment
chez moi je savais dès je ne l'avais
jamais dit publiquement et ouvrir
beaucoup de monde qu'il savait en fait
mais je sais pas publiés ouais je trouve
que c'est important d'en parler
justement parce que j'ai pas demandé ce
que j'en pensais ou quelque chose comme
ça toi oui ta famille un jour des textos
ans que je me suis posée à long terme
adam savage pas bien je suis sauvage
c'est une question de genre mais
d'offrir ces gros mais la demande est au
dessus et tu plus jaloux de ta blonde
parce que votre sport qu'une faillite à
vol
c'est pas juste un gars qui peut tu as
volé c'est aussi une fille que je flashe
resto quelqu'un d'autre ça serait à
cause que notre couple personnes flashé
à cause que par et flasher et là
j'entends jours débutant tour mais la
tête haute on me parlait dernièrement en
fait genre en fin de semaine yuri dos
des maisons mais il nous a demandé d'
enfant sa mère à lui des problèmes avec
ces simples en fait assez fait lever
pluie nous a écrit pour dire
higuain est ce que vous pourrez partager
cette pétition là pour que santé canada
bastien lui nous demander de partager sa
demande de licence et regarder puis
demain j'avais tout à vidéo à toi puis
on s'est regardé et on s'est dit j'ai
vraiment pas assez d'informations sur ce
j'ai l'impression qu'il faudrait qu'ils
avaient beaucoup de postes d'études
qu'ils soient mis sur ce problème sur la
situation
c'est son problème mais c'est ça aussi
le problème parce que est ce que j'ai
dans mes lectures récemment le fait un
gros et puis la conclusion c'est pas de
conclusion encore une fois juste pour
résumer il ya une minorité de femmes qui
a pris une opération d'augmentation
mammaire ont des symptômes le plus
bizarre j'en dois continuer comme une
qui hérite des nausées juste pas de quoi
battre sans problème what i qui dit
qu'ils pensent ichou y aller musée
tussaud à leur augmentation à voir
l'expo en lever les impôts
est-ce que c'est l'effet placebo ses
yeux posés dessus de la voie quand vos
choix je pense que ç'a pris à plus
d'études comme ça mais faut bien qu'il y
en fait c'est les fabricants problème
je pense que ça devrait vraiment changé
puisse expliquer comme ça pour n'importe
quoi et qui passe sous santé canada
c'est les fabricants qui font leur
propre nom mais non je pense qu'on est
d'accord dans l'anecdote commence à
peine et boissons sapant les études
scientifiques mettent toujours bien
senti et prendre opérations et bientôt
en fait c'est que cette anecdote dans le
fossé en même temps c'est l'effet
placebo ça existe mais tu sais ce que
c'est même démontré même si même si tu
sais que tu te donnes un placebo soit
quand même pour des symptômes de placebo
et démontrer mais ton subconscient et
comme même si ton concept où couraient
comme annoncé en effet qui est fort plus
fort qu'on pense
mais les études comparatives seulement
le groupe placebo y avoir des bienfaits
de mes préférés c'est dans un bar il y
avait 2
king of pop est mort est ce qu'ils les
groupes b savaient pas ce qu'ils veulent
et virgin toute la soirée puis à faire
la souris est chaud mais ils démontrent
les attitudes est aussi choqué le monde
de déboucher au pacte et autun morvan
autant le placebo qui eux aussi humble
ambiance où tout le monde ce matin avec
je mange pas un souci ça devient sa bio
tech mais moi je pense aussi que kate
est avec quelqu'un qui dans un certain
wayne state sur la trappe chauffante je
vois les guets-apens scientifique le
sait comme ces trois personnes avec
lesquelles tu tiens plus si quelqu un
dans ton entourage à qui tu veux pas
ressembler essaie de passer moins de
temps avec lui
si tu dit j'aimerais cependant inclus
mais mesdames ce bon ok je pense que
l'effet placebo est très fort c'est
peut-être ce qui arrive pour exister
comprennent qu'un lot on le sait peu
mais est ce que c est ce qu on veut que
la phase de recherche oui qu'est-ce
qu'on veut que les familles soient
conscientes que n'importe quel chien
giraumon ça peut être dangereux car il
ya du monde pour des opérations vraiment
mineur qui réveille jamais senti mettons
une opération en opération sacrer
manathan toutefois de rire m'en fous
hockey de terribles je veux comme tu as
les sources mais c'est 100% vrai patient
à montréal qui est arrivé ici ribéry
il se faisait opérer ils sont trompés
quelque chose j'adore tous les temps la
centrale à la chine qui met même ses
chances de tromper ça peut arriver est
arrivé
cette fois le glanage font peser une
menace son joli ces bébés avaient
couvert gens imaginent étaient trop
petits fichiers
il s'est trompé de fichiers comme la
floride et la lui avait plus de jambes
mais comme tout ce passé que ces mineurs
comme simon ph le corps les personnes
que je connaissais y travailler avec lui
hobscot logique parce que c'est comme si
moi je suis maintenant par opérer le
ministre ça va être comme si moi c'est
off de cours au complet la même façon
mais non mais des histoires comme ceux
d'histoire comme cela m'a valu quatre
consultants professionnels qui criait
une raison qui fait que c'est ça fait
que la vidéo que tu as fait tout ce qui
est expliqué sur canal
weight apprêtons à un exact puisque
c'est que positif enfants et moi même
chanceuse mais je continue de vérifier
les signes de mon corps parce que je
triche
oui j'y crois j'y crois j'y crois pas je
sais pas j'ai pas de preuve mais je vais
quand même continuer d'aller coûte 2
moi même parce que si jamais il ya quoi
que ce soit je trouve important de
réagir vite en mairie maison 2a maison
puis ça m'amène à une autre vidéo que de
fait que j'ai trouvé vraiment
intéressante avec la personne à sexuelle
oui c'est un coup de gueule
j'aurais aimé que ça sur mon ami je le
trouvais tellement inquiète est drôle et
toute la conversation cool et s'était
excusé moi toujours c'est le spécimen
parfait pour montrer aux gens que ses
covenants ma sexualité s'arrêtait une
femme il y aurait des gens qui est
réputé s'arrêter un jour venir les gens
qui répétaient des secteurs où il ya
toujours des raisons mais j'étais
tellement contente le et son âge son
sexe et sa façon d'être
tout était si vous êtes plus répit que
vous connaissez pas les asexuels des
gens qui ont peu ou pas de désir sexuel
par exemple vous allez voir la vidéo
très exactement pour ça au début que je
avant qu'on commence à parler je sais
pourquoi j'ai pour que je sais que c'est
cool
le genre de vidéos vous faites les deux
c'est que ces deux affaires qu'on parle
pas on aucune crise des ses excuses à la
tribune pour en parler ça mais c'est
aussi moins dans le fond j'ai toujours
fait ce depuis le début les choses qui
m'intéressent seulement ouais si ces
caches passionné ça paraît qu'ils
puissent et moi je suis incapable de
jouer une game technology de la mesure
non respect pour deco quelqu'un parce
que c'est bon pour ma carrière à kindu
c'est donc donc sa chose pour que la
main que je fais mes vidéos puis c'est
certainement comme ce que j'ai fait ma
vidéo dans matin le jour de noël ou
juste comme vous voyez vous ces
pratiques aussi parce que tu dis à moins
bons qu'ils nous écoutent mais ceux qui
nous écoutent pour de vrai ouais moi
juste j'eus dernièrement j'en parlais
avec jesse je te main méthon
je regarde mes temps mais stade
d'instagram c'est un chiffre des mesures
et le timon nombre d'abonnés le sûr que
je me dis je pense que je préférerais
en avoir le tiers de toutes mes demandes
qui a pour mission le juste pour ce que
je fais c'est pas parce que j'ai déjà
fait donc se rôder dans ce cas ci mais
juste pour ce que je fais c'est direct
mca les gros déficit comme je comprends
ce que tu faisais c'est quand même une
chance que tu es dans sa série gros défi
d'avoir une célébrité instantanée dans
ce sens où au moins donne un mégot
boosté à tant de temps servait pour le
bien pour le mal ou pourriez pente eu
lieu ce soir à s'échapper la tribune est
bon pour faire des bonnes choses il ya
des choses qui demandent ce qu'ils vont
faire mais c'est comme tout se défend
mais c'est très deep ce qu'un taxi d'un
gros chiffre rapidement de 2 comme ceux
de faire du ménage dans désormais après
parce que c'est pas mal les verts et hu
jui jefferies qui va apporter une
certaine popularité instantanée au début
mes gommes jetez pas sur you to c gepa
des jets facebook et blois propres mais
quand même les j'ai accepté par tout le
monde il acceptait juste le monde qui
déniait me répondre je connais du monde
il est beau mais écoutez donc après
c'est aussi une étape à la fois ses
enfants dans la foi pin je pense que
c'est comme plus facile lorsque l'aide
avant meilleur contrôle sur son lot de
stop ça serait engagée parce que sinon
tout tellement de l'ong se ressemblent
pour les dix huit mais ce que je voulais
dire c'est maintenant un appel aux gens
qui s'en câlisse de ce que je fais des
abonnés jettera ses abonnés bah non il
faut un mariage ma méthode est simple je
me dis pourquoi désabonnez vous arrêtez
le monde et attendent le moment est ce
que je veux
c'est probablement qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde qui attendent juste que s'il ya
tarifs parce qu'ils se disent aussi
l'algorithme doit pas aider parce que la
galerie fait que les gens oublient dans
son numéro exact factice et pas je sais
c'est que moi je le vois aussi puisque
aurait pas ce que l'on peut s'en servait
dansant sous genre c'est vrai que ça
fait chier parce que trop d'engagement
moins bon mais en même temps peut quand
même s'attendre à des fois je le vois
même en mode mais quand je vois faire de
quoi qu'il va être ultra pas l'algue
rainbow six
l'afutt vous croisez juin 10 pts auront
le goût français et avec quel beau mais
sort des chiffres de malade mental parce
que l'apix et comme selon le vent il
nourrit le temps de les voir descendre
qu'il me suis levé beaucoup en tant que
non pas plein central et qu'un souhait
d'école avec des gros youtube à ces
bateaux comme moi j'ai déjà fait une
grosse vidéo avec m'a dit matt busby
qu'il vous est pris aux années qui sont
des gueux qui était très peu plus tôt
plaques - mais côté on aime être
ensemble explosion d'abonnés à ce niveau
le dg qui ont capoté sa vidéo puis qui
sont juste le 15 août avec donc temps me
dit maintenant mieux se sont encore là
mais c'est vrai que sur les quatre
gardes tu existes attentes assez fatigué
et puis même pour toi moi je marque je
remarque qu'il ya des personnes
auxquelles je m'abonne finalement
séduction ou si tout le monde peut il
est tout le monde et quand même pas mal
de réseaux sociaux mais est ce que c'est
vraiment comme 4,4 vedette sans quoi
honnêtement je pense qu'être séduction
lancée tout le monde mais tout le monde
tout le monde a un style tout le monde
qui sont ceux qui ont des réseaux
sociaux les qui sont actives 0 du mans
xtreme legends sociaux qui la question
se pose pour vrai parce que n'importe
qui dans ton fidh et du manque de
qualité des photos qui pense le pic
mais si ça nous aussi pour le faire
c'est un mode je me mens mais bon si je
drague peau je dois d abord parce que
c'est jusqu'au bonnet tellement demande
à comparaître - je comprends pas comment
tu fais pour le ph de cette journée le
nom puis démonter la seule étude il est
garde faite par facebook puis d une
berceuse qu'elle ait un impact sur ce
que tu vois sur ton fut donné pâques sur
ton dimanche
ok j'exagère peut mieux résumer ça a été
une très bien documenté mais aussi il
trop
controversé puissent apporter 13 et
icloud à qui l'on fait mais facebook se
sont joués à l'université et ils y ont
fait naître sur l'humeur les usagers
puis en gros
il ya plein de conclusion de ce tour le
genre qu une belle journée à boston
impact sur l'humeur tout le monde se
pose dès aujourd'hui radio cassette avec
twitter aussi
javari voyez quel mode c'était
directement lié à aux équipes de sport
de cette ville le pouvoir sont en trop
c'est en prenant sur l'actualité des
gens sur facebook à qui il voyait avec
des mots clé qu'est ce qui était
possible négatif active est tombée
encore thor aux gens ce maudit françois
legault facilement devenu si c'est
négatif positif comme publication qui a
brillé il prenait le monde
notre méthode y montrait plus de positif
que plus de négatif à ces gens là il y
avait plus de chance que les prochains
statut de ces gens le souhait du le côté
de ce qui se sont fait autrement dit si
tu connaissais amphi de bonne humeur et
d avoir envie de faire une statue de
bonne humeur
souvent dit presque fâché contre les
policiers mais je t'envie des forges est
tout aussi bon je pense que ses fans de
faire du corps nus pose c'est fou ce
léger défaut si les jeunes avancée à mon
message vocal à personne fait une photo
un cours du coach qui m'a fait que
négativement par comme ceci car elle
enlève le double parce que ça là ça non
plus isoler complètement négatif est ce
que tu disais tantôt dit étudier on est
la moyenne des cinq personnes qui nous
écoutent
on est vraiment reflètent un
environnement d qui en coton et qu'est
ce qu'on fait à chaque jour dès qu'est
ce qu'on voit chaque jour puis j'ai même
fait la job pire internet parce que mes
mots je pense comme toi moi mon facebook
- et agréable et c'est vraiment un
contrôle et pour que ce que je vois ça
m'influence positivement ces mouches
guitariste dans le vif et si j'essaie de
l'eau démons instagram de mondragon a
envie de faire pareil ce que je vaux
longueur de journée c'est du monde
vraiment meilleur que moi et que tu as
fait tu le sais ce que ça a une
influence sur mon nom ma progression
bon faut pas que ça fait pas ce pigiste
à mater bon mettons des méthodes du
monde qui pose juste des affaires
anti-musulmans maintenant sur facebook
ne vous j'en ai gardé un ok j'en ai
gardé un oeil dans mon facebook
distinguo qui a vécu j'ai fait de la
musique à l'université
pis ils posent test-achats mal utilisé
des vidéos de mines anti musulmane va
pas vraiment ce qui est réel et ce qui
se passe est isolé dans la vie
il est enfin ok oui la marque et la
haine biais de l'isolation les psycho
isolé c'est eux qui sera manche soit
soit explosant sur les colos state ou à
combattre pour l'été cela mais c'est le
même problème mais deux spectres
différents néonazis ou gens tellement du
match on veut tuer les américains
ce c'est parce que tu étais tout seul
parce que l'humain son animal social
pixellisation qui mène à peu près à
toutes les problèmes incluant les
dépendances aux drogues ou d'alcool et
inclurait les religieux et c'est pour ça
je pose la question parce qu'ils
montrent qu'ils ont des mauvaises par
speechi peuvent se faire mal informés
puis kiki pitié je pense pas qu'ils vont
nécessairement âgées là dessus même si
c'est récurrent
ça peut valoir la peine oui je pense
j'ai côtoyé à l'extérieur du web parce
que des fois la personne qui était sur
le web qui était dans la vraie vie ce
défaut il ya quand même les cadres est
facile d'avoir une fonction de monsieur
genre de bonhomme tu aimais surface par
gentil thiên nhân a medic se met à
parler de sujets comme étant le
réchauffement climatique ou non mais
c'est pas vrai et pis mais moi j'ai
vraiment l'impression que c'est juste
que lui tranquillement son facebook
c'est pour lui d'en faire comme c'est un
gaucher pat à dire mais je pense plus
jose avec les gentils mais ils disposent
tous togolais ya une conscience une
intelligence hors du commun justement
son environnement au web notamment ce
qu'il l'influencé chaque jour ce qui
voit chaque jour
c'est ce que je lui dis tu voyais des
bars et mettons tout fait ces connexions
journée l'up le en l'espace de cinq
minutes et à partager ses vidéos ses
vies
puis c'est comme ça aussi le problème
pour personne à qui parler ou non pas
depuis ce col mais bon le quidam on
pourrait vraiment non même lorsqu'une
foule mais marc lafaille banques qui ont
des vies de marc de l'été on a tout des
défis d'invités si ta personne book avec
qui partager ce mais le tchèque a
trouvées d'aider des coupables
pis les échos parlent eux les coupables
des fois c'est les musulmans des fossés
les illuminati des fossés justin trudeau
des fois c'est les environnementalistes
des fossés québec soldats pour faire
preuve d'empathie envers ces gens là
parce que souvent sont paumés chanson
juste mal informés mais à gauche ou si
calme en a pas de l'esprit qui recyclent
à gauche puis à droite on a des mieux qu
on a déjà intelligence et a fait même
est donc et c'est ce que je constate et
puis j'ai un filtre et les passants de
chambre aux états unis pendant pendant
l'élection fréquence 2012 2012 a mis
près de recensement je le voyais aussi
le c'est pas du monde méchant c'est
justement qu'ils se sentent plus
représentés beaucoup de l'amérique
rurale
on a aussi aussi en ontario puis on a eu
aussi au québec en injection lopy on
échange au québec.le parce que notre
droite bonhomme le sais françois legault
qui on n'est pas vraiment d'extrême et
non non surtout de respect pour moi je
suis un optimiste georges de beauce qui
risque sans bavure
j'avais des choses intéressantes qui ont
souhaité inclure la réforme électorale
mon françois ce pacte va rester seul
maître douleur on surveille la jeunesse
de survie mais bref
donc on est chercher parce que ce n'est
pas un scoop c'est comme dans une fois
dans l'ontario puis en coupe de places
en europe où c'est arrivé
le brésil c'est arrivé c'est la région
points se reconnaît plus exigeants les
élites intellectuelles et médiatiques
pas qu'ils se reconnaissent plus dans
les émissions télé ils se reconnaissent
plus dans la culture web parce que ça va
trop vite pour pâques là il semble
qu'elle a saisi pour plus bêtes que
publics sont comme fox nous notre
identité où on a pas d'émissions télé
qui parlant nous présentement on a moins
de moyens qu'ils noueraient présent
notre voie nous dans les communautés
rurales et que j'étais leur on pense au
québec de tradition catholique tss ça
existe encore c'est qu'il faut pas
regarder ces gens de l'eau de haut parce
que ils ont pour leur humanité puis
l'accès récemment pour habiter dans la
modernité comme plusieurs d'entre nous
donc la paix chose à faire c'est les
regarder de haut puis les traiter de
raciste parce que c'est comme ceux qui
vont s'isoler mais il s'est radicalisé
bien que rim devenait comme le gars que
tu viens de mentionner des antilles dès
le départ les douches pas douce par jour
pas que là il faut nous au québec le
faut amener des gens positifs en région
pis les écouter puis il ya des russes et
des médias qui s'intéressent au site et
vo c'est le seul poste qui parle au
monde des régions c'est pas mal son
équipe on se met à penser comme tout bon
donc
c'est à tout le monde de faire une
démarche qui que ce soit un des amis de
ce fabuleux qui propose aller prendre
une bière puis qui propose d'aller
manger un après midi où genre jusque là
était sûr que ça vaut mais je te
recommande la platelle numéro parce
qu'il y ait des descentes qui public de
djihad les gens j'ai fait ça m'aide à
face à bari j'ai commenté son truc donc
30 radicaliser j'ai mis un petit lien de
gens ressentent de prétendre à la crise
à sion ces couacs et publiquement tu
fais politique ont presque fait ma
barrows mais c'est pas fou c'est parce
que c'est vrai mais c'est tout pourrait
attaquer dû appeler le centre de
prévention
l'hymne de santé mentale c'est aussi
pour l'entourage la personne la place
non mais ça peut te répondre à des
questions aussi peuvent choquer c'est
vraiment un an je veux sont pas moins
que tout bon là-dedans facture ça
pourquoi et le foot je suis rassuré
attaquer les services sont là on échange
sur steam pour toujours pas refait mon
canada
on est quand même extrêmement sur les
services gratuits de santé et de santé
mentale nous on a beaucoup travaillé à
la clé il faut juste parler aux gens
pourquoi capable de l'essayer puis le
gumbri master davantage le plus investi
en santé mentale au moment où sa santé
physique parce que c'est leur vie ses
geôliers pour ça que mon vieux parce
qu'on va en avoir de plus en plus et
faut aussi enseigné la santé mentale
mais ça me paraît pas tout de suite il
faut écouter ces gens là aussi voulu les
juger - tpiy oui j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya une chose qui a drainé la balance
c'est vraiment un feeling plus que
quelques données objectives mais titre
en pl
il vraiment tout plein d'imperfections
ces primes et autres figures politiques
se mettront au bas mot tout est bien
mieux outre avoir le bon mot pitt y
incarne il ya une perfection [ __ ]
quand toi tu cites est un parfait parce
que reconnaître la personne notamment
acquis qui clairement l époque que même
là vous il lui manque que la personne
n'attaque love qui est un opus qui fait
se bâtissent un jeune homme qui fait ce
bénévole d'une communauté urbaine a sévi
pts et jusqu'à mais c'est comme ça
george bush a été élu un léger ultra un
film de fiction que son personnage plus
gros personnage aussi beaucoup plus
jeune mais j'ai été besoin du visible
les américians soit président en
fonction d'eux avec y répondre à cause
de quoi
à cause du fait que les gens se disaient
c'est fini on le voit espèce de mouche
sur un pic de 7 globes mais si c'est
vraiment arrivé comme ce genre de
technique c'est assez gauche les
réactions c'est comme des pionniers
comme moi j'ai fait l'armée moi je suis
spécialiste dans leur politique
étrangère sécurité in line up to son
curriculum de gens armés petit pick up
pizza à george bush
d'abord occupé depuis tout est plongeur
la phase de l'opération piliers comme je
dis qu'obama
j'adore aux bahamas une explication pour
moi mais c'est vrai que si t'es con plus
politiquement et qui se trouve bavure
pic qui tout sourit plus regardée au
piquet de ph et occupation double peine
c'est en france
c'est l'impression que parce qu'ils
posent et puis fait la bonne affaire
il fait le bon disent qu ils raison
masse qui dit de la pression s'est
nettement ward saragosse c'est vraiment
une pile je dis pas ça va c'est moi mais
c'est une bonne analogie la patente que
je regarde maintenant maintenant que
j'irai coup ses émissions le gpad syrien
qui était pas vrai d'accord je te
défendre est sûre ce mémo la gourde est
joué vous trouvez que tel mais sans
caméras les pays bric étaient là avec
mes amis comme jean le pan du chemin
non mais je sais j'y arrive je défendrai
beaucoup là dessus parce que beaucoup de
jeunes je m'identifiais ton personnage
de vue qui restent posées dans une
altercation
mais si je fais ce ça la met encore plus
en tabarnak
c'est le monde toutes mes amis aussi
quand dans une altercation verbale mots
je les scanne chic et choc moi je les
scanne toulon sont comme dans
l'impression que des gens ton
paternaliste tout neuf ans je n'accepte
pas de laisser mes émotions pour devenir
un agent de boules des rares taxis
mais ce ses penchants pour connaître le
pied comme tous les émotions
écoutez j'ai je sais quoi sur le weebe
c'est moi je te voyais ma pensée moi je
trouvais de gilles dal et des baux ou
comme c'était comme si délicate diktat
tout le monde un mode jean galmot so
sexy so peas et comme je suis qu'à ma
surprise mais
la maison blanche et aussi parce que le
monde regarde garder leur calme les
stations comme ça c'est faux chèque et
que ça revient aussi au végétalisme
l'appel enfin nous c'est franchement
envie s'affairent à confronter un style
de vie qui est peut-être meilleur que le
6 mai ont eu lieu n'ont jamais pensé
aspire sur le sur le coup facile le
bulletin est ce la même chose et me
demande si une raison que les généraux
négativement cat stevens et
immédiatement il fonde la projection en
mode mais moi je fais possible donc
sûrement moins bonne humeur dans le nom
lustres moins bonne humeur devant la
maison sont comme des lustres lustin
moins bonnes mais parce qu'ils restent
calmes tout le monde devrait expirer à y
rester car dans ces sept on s'en fout il
marche 30% mieux quand je fais c'est la
négociation des terroristes des otages
le gueux qui se saluent tu parles de qui
vote sous la barre seul ou non ce stade
je l'écris pivot des conférences ou
lancôme a négocié pour connaître
l'origine humaine qu'il habiterait trop
calme plat salle fesci bien tout le
monde l'exemple il faut être à globo ces
gens faut être comme pouet pouet smythe
même se pencher eux qui viennent sur six
personnes que c'est karaoké
- il faut que ce soit comme un salut ça
va sûrement parce que le cerveau humain
cahiers dans une position socialement
intéressant ils fonctionnent à moins de
30% mieux de davies et moi j'ai décidé
la pied de jeter un gosse matin gérard
bailly d'aller encore plus loin jean
tout dans les situations au resto outre
on est pressés ou gentil à la caisse à
l'épicerie ou quelque chose
moi je prends le temps de revoir ce
match j'ai eu l'impression qu'ils sont
plus efficaces comme que je combats tout
ça et pas plus le cadre est juste resté
très bon donc
chicanes de couple pour une chicane
politique si les deux passes y rester
calme sur mac leurs sabots marcherait
mieux pas qu'ils pourraient trouver de
meilleures solutions on laisse passer
des fois ça fait bien aussi je prends
une maison c'est juste pour regarder
l'exemple politique dans le débat des
chefs le sait le débat des chefs
volerait vraiment plus haut c'est tout
le monde était juste une coche en
dessous le parfum de coupe de développer
des barreaux petit fils fan de plantes
et leurs défauts mais l'arrêté ces
personnes plantent vraiment personne
évidemment des stratégies d'aidé
d'argumentation de déplacer beaucoup
d'écoles primaires où c'est peut-être ça
marche pas tu veux être celui qui parle
le plus longtemps c'est que le plus de
temps de parole
le moment tendance à dire à mes six
personnes probablement pas toi mais
peut-être quelqu'un qui regarde chez eux
le juge démographique mais vivement
qu'ils regardent chez eux qui qui peut
être naturelle à faire sur le thème
choisi le meilleur si c'est comme si
humain aussi
ouais mais le gifas secours l'homme
estiment qu'au sommet de la dune qui dit
se montre un cheval fort dans une course
folle à non verbale évidemment la
philosophie de cet homme c'est juste
qu'ils sortent c'est sûr que c'est un
individu absolument horrible mais qui a
réussi à faire des grandes choses
horribles mais non mais y a personne qui
est complètement dépassé
la gironde qui lisent minecraft le
rebond amorcé un nazi mais en mode je
veux comprendre l'histoire puis moi
c'est un peu glauque et bien que c'est
qu'au fond c'est quoi sa mentalité pour
réussir à faire le coup du aussi
dégueulasse qui épie donc ça s'applique
aussi dans les débats citoyens d'avoir
gagné le monde y pense que la plupart du
temps maintenant supporter ces bétons il
se passe ce qui se passe de quoi tu
penses qu'il eut clairement maintenant
tu lance la rondelle benchmark points un
but et se lève les bras de personnels
[Musique]
arbitres le 6 mai d'où l'importance
avoir beaucoup plus d'éducation en fait
le sujet en fait la curiosité des gens
ils vont donc arriver à l'éducation
ouais parce que c'est très complexe ça
commence très jeune mais fait que ça m'a
plu c'est alors que les intéresse pas la
politique était maman oui mais peut-être
parce qu'ils sont peut-être que pensez
toujours à bien cravate expliquait il le
peuple et pauvrement représenter ses
mots c'est une démarche de cangé
interview le premier ministre québec
mais le coup hier à l'époque nous sommes
qu'à ouais c'est ça s'arrange en blanc
paru chez moi pauvre je suis je veux
dire mais j'ai pas votre québec cesse
d'appeler des programmes avec certaines
le souhait de leur plafond mais j'ai une
grande inspiration pour ce qu'ils font
sur l'apport des gens qui militent très
fort dans cette partie le devant et
derrière les micros mais catherine
dorion même si je peux la grecque tout
ce qui est des fins omagad que je trouve
ceci je pense plutôt à la main franche
et légers ils pensent que c'est
c'est futile et bien sûr son lot de tee
shirt i mais comme non les gens se
reconnaissent pas dans la politique
donc c'est le débat que la cause est ce
parce que les vrais enjeux
sauf que moi je suis derrière pour sa
tête en même temps que ça prenne plus de
ce parce que les vrais enjeux
nous allons les vrais enjeux ça fait des
décennies qu'on n'en parle aussi ce que
ça prenne plus de place que les vrais
enjeux ça fait que le film king par
rapport à la patente ce qui va amener
plus de monde à saintes et
éventuellement tous et toutes ces
polémiques les autos de son habillement
ce décorum d'une politique puisque ça le
vraiment amener les yeux sur elle qui a
fait que son discours à la fin des
nationales ou ska parle de solitude avec
son petit jeu de patrice desbiens a été
vu énormément de fois bien plus que six
mètres
elle fait très bien mais mais la
substance et les autres systèmes qui les
destinent que kevin et ont été créés
sauf que son discours était vraiment bon
titre big bang qui qui l'ont attaqué
juste par idéologie politique est aussi
le seuil et dénonce un tel club de
crenca qui m la rationalité poubelles
juste pour aller chercher du clip peace
c'est leur job je suis pas là comme
contre nature mais c'est un fait qui est
désolé des sexes le big bang son attaque
assez juste parce que c'est juste un
autre en chine gbagbo temps ci au québec
soldats mais j'ai juste envie de faire 1
1 à caudry qui dit 2000e est de monsieur
je sais j'en le manchot mais comme les
médiums c'est le message pierre son
médium elle réussit à l'adapter à la au
message que celle du brics à dire que
tout le monde est impliqué là dedans
puis peu importe
klein et de gaspiller un territoire à la
pollution
pierre
meetic quand on parle des vrais enjeux
de source intéressante c'est parce que
mouche quand même j'ai comment un flip
idéologique récemment où je pense qu'il
faut bien sûr continent améliorer le
plus possible nos sociétés mais c'est
vraiment pendant la campagne politique
provinciale que je me suis comme dit ata
menottes
un des enjeux c est ce qu on devrait
faire des langes pour les parents à quel
point ça vaut ben oui j'ai bec en
général pour que ce soit sur les
réflexions ses com
oui c'est vrai c'est vraiment c'est long
les temps d'attentes à l'urgence à
samonac su rendre cette cote s'érode à
la psi jantes est en train de mourir ils
vont prendre dans la minute mais ce
temps when they come home staging
j'ai tout lâché ça coûte 3000 pièces à
moi même si j'allais plus loin
séquences choisies dans son serpent
chien qui mord 40 nous voyons c'est que
je m'offrais jacking charte de 4000
pièces
donc on quand on se compare on peut se
consoler au faucon sous d'améliorer non
nos sociétés en général mais c'est ça
aussi que j'ai compris pire beaucoup
justement j'en ai des amis qui sont un
peu plus intense dans la négative type
dans conspirationnistes défaut qui
croient pas sur les possibles fourré
gély big lebowski vécu après que la
politique c'est comme non mais le site
et année de 2,2 telle partie de son
agissement megan donc rejoint le picom
pour voter dans le parti puis comme
aliment change le chef depuis 2000 cher
et peu importe et qui coûtait quoi donc
visuellement mais changer je sais que
j'ai les équipes du monde qui essaye
sans compromis de foot choisi le parti
qui ressemble plus 5 60% en ligne
ces mêmes même gabriel dubois qui font
leur show sur le podcast mois sur le
banc qu'à se disait témoin et des
affaires de québec solidaire que je suis
pas d'accord d'accord mais qui dit on ne
peut pas avoir 100% ce que chaque
individu par chacun pour partie
s'annonçait compromis le travail
d'équipé juste des fois je l'amène à le
faire je pense que la jeune adversaire
demain c'est comme ça mais j'essaie de
prendre plus de distance possible de mon
affaire de la planète chaussures bon
exemple de comprendre plus de distance
possible pour mieux comprendre
4 le gouvernement le sait juste on a
juste fait des années et des années de
multi croisés comme je parle pas de la
mode comme l'organisme de des clés comme
la modélisation look sur les animaux
sociaux aubry comme nous mastiquer le
gouvernement c'est pas très long parce
que c'est quand même savoir alpha puis
cela me passe d'atik pas mal génétique
alors que nous le sommes comme dit
conscient des documents légaux il ya
comme de digix a fait des centaines
danic sont comme commerce coop le plus
possible organiser des biens
puis il ya des enjeux sur lesquels sa
gauche et sur lequel chez à droite mais
jantes allégées et comme auch contre le
capitalisme non mou deux coups de mieux
que moi c'est comme l'autre extrême ça
marche pas ils ont essayé parfait la
démocratie c'est un parcours assez les
meilleurs systèmes conte danse musique
moi je trouve que c'est l'imam système
équilibré comme malheureusement la
démocratie puis le fascisme ça bien en
vagues parents dans une vague je pense
que le fascisme et l'europe
nouveau mais dans le passé des
gouvernements jusqu'au matin c'est comme
cédé un set dans sa quête d'ancêtres que
tout ce qu'ils essaient de régis est une
structure sociale qui est on l'espère le
plus équitable possible pour le plus
souvent possible qui mérite d'être
amélioré avec une nouvelle chose qu'on a
découvert aujourd'hui mais comme on peut
supporter autre sac et aux poubelles je
pense que nous aurons donc un bâton qui
souhaitaient anarchiste c'est sûrement
parce que tu te sens les équipes pendant
qu'ils essaient de changer l'aspect du
10 août salle plus les plutôt que d'être
comme l'alternative c'est l'ataraxie
c'est la séquence de vivre d'entre nous
même en forêt ne pas avoir de sociétés
savantes ou punir mais oui je comprends
qu'il ya beaucoup de d'abstraction et de
réflexion là d'un pied je suis loin de
savoir quoi penser du gouvernement sauf
que je pense que monsieur de s'impliquer
peu importe où tu es dans la société
c'est comme ceux qui vont le plus
possible d'arrêter besoin c'est ça ce
que ça sophie réguler le marché parce
que le capitalisme pause ça marche pas
mais c'est quand même important d'en
faire bouger la main la main du marché
le plus intéressant genre
l'électrification des transports faisant
des lendemains meilleurs processus de
lettres est pas ce qu elles ont leurs
emplois disparaître
c'est comme ça c'est des ados le marché
règle d'or c'est même la pensée peut pas
parce qu'on parlait plutôt de
l'association la planète l'exploration
spatiale tout se tenir de grâce theissen
qui lui refusent d'être alarmiste
récemment alarmiste mais refuse d'être
pessimiste par la société dans ce qu'il
dit
grossièrement que de la minuk ça va
devenir un enjeu
[Musique]
économiques et monétaires las la science
bonneveine sortir de chez arm d'accord
de bras ça donne vraiment une grande foi
pouvoir la science j'imagine que c'est
ce que votre décision incroyable ce
qu'il soit à la hauteur
chef de file pour le fun j'ai fait pour
le fun qui volaient inverse
premièrement de toutes les époques des
mayas aujourd'hui on l'a toujours pensé
que c'était notre génération qui
allaient vers la fin du monde le brésil
vit avec les changements climatiques
nous avons des films des documentaires
des années 90 il y avait déjà greenpeace
qui avait déjà du monde sans sa critique
ping il remonte en examen 80 c'est tout
différent et admettons blade runner et à
la même chose qu'on descend du singe
tout le monde pense que c'est la fin du
monde en permanence l'église catholique
jean de l'islam c'est juste là on se
prépare pour la fiction comme on se bat
pour notre mandat nous met you le monde
au contexte et nous comptons mettre les
cannes dès la fin 2011
oui exactement ce que je faisais ce que
définitivement
on a tendance à exagérer les menaces
mais il faudrait ag oui mais je pense
que si on arrête de s'auto flageller sur
les petites dans l'édition
parce que je sache que c'est au début
une seconde qui font de l'anxiété par
rapport à plat national écrit des
lettres comme sait déjà qui ont des
carrières intéressantes
c'est un musicien saison extraordinaire
ils paniquent parce que genre les appels
de marge de la société pas assez
féministe puis parce que l'on va mourir
ce jeu mathématique demain ces deux
enjeux très importants
aucun on peut choisir d'accorder sa vie
ou non mais s'il vous plaît gardons une
perte ce genre froide
ça c'est de penser à ce psy d'agir dans
ce sale nuit ton développement dans une
personne perds ta santé mentale au fait
que tout du plaisir sa planète terre qui
devrait sûrement être ton futur numéro
en la chose numéro un du doigt m avait
visé un monument et puis avoir deux
les sur l'environnement tout le test
nuit blanche à deux morts le second qui
vont faire à ta place 52 des
scientifiques à la nasa qui met des
enfants sur mars si comme on veut on va
figurer la voie juste par l'opac 6 pi
c'est beaucoup saigné aux gestes gandhi
c'est un groupe un guichet mais cbi de
cheng ji hwan beyond the sword
j'étais comment commence par le
changement que tu peux faire tout comme
tous mangent bio hôpitaux 68 ou sopo
sexy sont vitaux par un peu mais comme
si de toute façon cette nuit ben je fais
de la natation je l'étais la première
chose qu'on apprend dans le cours de
l'argonne
avant d'aider quelqu'un doit être sûrs
qu'on est en sécurité avant d'essayer de
sauver le mont sutton be nice
kythera tout état laïque elle a des
besoins primaires seront comblés
incluant l'alimentation la maison et les
amis gens que tu veux une vie sociale
intéressant et comme ça ses priorités ce
soit devant un job dans ville
mais quand 6e réussit à avoir tout sauf
le père se construit la supplie
mais si tu mets la planète à 20 des
besoins à toi tes besoins réalise le
cycle d'investissement joueurs bourrés
de rejouer comme georges le même été des
besoins de base qui sont comblés mais
comme ça devrait abriter de me voir
avant de faire de l'anxiété à savoir
cela que johanne blouin pendant des gars
comme le king de la cité sur les
ajustements sur la valeur tout c'est lui
puis l'ont ils pas ce niveau là mais
c'est sa maîtrise des personnes les plus
intègres sa planète et je comprends qu
est ce que tout les scientifiques qui
s'entend là-dessus pitt c'est dans le
fond on le sait peu mais été étudiées
comme ségolène avait compris mais là
mais il ya peut-être portant sur un
certain point dans un sens ou juste pour
le fun james juste jouer avocat du
diable
c'est peut-être une bonne chose a fait
lui mentais peut-être qu'il va devenir
rawlings et john heileman pis on est le
cerveau de la planète roadster il se
réunit les web avec un communiqué en
mode disco le
peut-être la meilleure affaire
finalement on comprend tout
imagine touristes d'avoir comme une
image est aussi le moment où on ne sait
qu'il va tantôt notre symbiose avec
notre téléphone c'est là qu'ils on est
unique il ya en tout temps j'ai accès à
gauche sans réfléchir
mais peut-être que ça vaut aussi
développer l'empathie peut-être que je
réponds bah maintenant perdre la tête de
la personne en cours des deux mois pour
me mettre dans time with music et
universal ont finalement fait que j'ai
l'oeil nu comme ça c'est un rêve mais
pas aux reptiles et l'est
et vive et un bal masqué bref vivement
mentalité ça va passer par on va appeler
applaudi nos cerveaux dans un dans une
audi puis on a vu là dedans si vous
n'êtes pas de motivation votre sac et là
dedans claque pour des milliers date se
jouer à kindi cloche retentit à ce que
tu disais tantôt par rapport à toujours
voir les mâles vivent être bien avec toi
même avant de pouvoir changer les cgc a
fait a fait souvent des détachements des
moments tendres que tlc les animaux ça
touche tellement la difficulté à
constamment t2 feront parce qu'en plus
il ya quelqu'un qui se met de l'avant
par rapport à social de tic puis c'est
plus un vrai fond et puis elle a à
l'écouté des conférences sur le
l'activisme sustainable donc comment
réussir à prendre soin de toi pour être
capable de mieux prendre soin des autres
et puis ça je pense que c'est vraiment
important de le faire comme ça c'est
cool
si toi tu es pas capable de vivre au
quotidien à cause que tu vois tout ce
qui se passe dans le monde est en train
de détruire les curieux qui jetaient des
tournages l'autre jour je n'avais pas la
personne mes bons amis qui y en a même
dans un petit resto y ballon on a eu la
même s'ils restent aux billets étaient
aux commandes un lange que tout ça soit
les brebis
il s'assoit pied danser manger puis
comme j'ai soif mais j'ai vu que par don
josé valence drôme où je vois toujours
attendre je vais attendre prochain
tournage pour boire bardot jeter comme
pardon il dit on n'aurait pas un des
poèmes du plastique tac ont leurs
propres règles et prendre de l'essence
parce que le plastique c'est un sous
produit
la cen-sad c'est un des résidus du
pétrole qui a ancré de l'essence à domme
du plastic bag c'est quand même cool
qu'on fasse des choses plus de cela avec
peut-être que de saumos est pas là mais
lyon a quand même son charme et ses
cités mais c'est un charlot
c'est juste un plot bois ton frère
d'aupic sommes importantes à bonal james
mais c'est juste moi ça me sentais aussi
à quel point c'est quand même assez
engagé et l hygiène en place beaucoup de
lait c'est la personne qui voulait plus
tôt c'est la gauche qui boit tous les
verres d'eau aussi il faut qu'il
demandait pitié automatiquement affichée
[Musique]
est autonome on conduit deschamps
récente
il va falloir qu'on fasse de quoi que le
plastique résultats kt et moi je pense
que c'est vraiment juste personnes
devraient pas réserver le plus le plus
durable possible actifs qui construit
des maisons durham en plastique qui
colle en rien aux besoins ont besoin
le seo forme tempo la mer investissement
en termes d'espacé de pollueur parce que
ça va exemple combien dire c'est comme
ta santé avant la santé de la planète
qui accroît la santé des personnes
s'étaient mal entre personnes s'étaient
pas capable de battre personne ce
dernier je sais quoi m'attendre dans le
cas du véganisme et on le tire justement
pour reprendre l'exemple l'exemple de
mme ablonczy
si tu es heureuse puis tu transpires le
bonheur peut bien être tu vois ton un
paquebot est dix fois plus qu'un ses
classiques et sitôt l'argent dans le
corps des animaux thor ça me fait penser
je pense tu es gimont
il y avait quelqu'un qui avait publié
quand comme quoi c'est miss kha mun le y
avait peut-être des les traces anima
devant un piteux piszczek prend des
pilules
ça démontre à quel point les gens s
construit une identité dans leurs
revendications puisque extrême en
dessous des gérer ça ensuite parce que
l'identité c'est vraiment important chez
les u21 la peur de perdre quelque chose
qui va voir ses seins nos sentiments les
plus jeunes les plus gros orage il pleut
c'est comme si je faisais mes
personnages les peaux sèches et l'enlève
des gommes bros alors que ça c'est comme
le furent placés bègue l'identité ou si
c'est énorme
viguier militaires les bonnes causes
s'allier tellement proches dans leur
identité que le cisi et lamouchi bien
avant d'être médicamenté le conflit
n'était pas d'image entre le profond en
parallèle imagine tout cas ce que tu as
parlé paire de tongs dentiste et ce qui
est beaucoup le coja touati et beaucoup
de beaucoup de jeunes gens qui ont voté
les gaufres et ou trump ceux qui
n'avaient pas de disparaît donc il était
comme ça absolument quelque chose puis
il faut réfléchir à cela par perdre
quelque chose c'est exagéré se calmer là
dessus la sexualité c'est la clé la
flexi les deux ça marche cela qui
l'excité et sexualité au lieu d'inciter
ses la communauté c'est pourquoi quand
viggen on met les tickets de l'igen
spassky communauté qui vient de se
passer c'est reviens à mon ami l'autre
jour qui est vraiment que la seule
communauté qui ouvre les brosses la
communauté de ceux qui partagent les
enfants anti musulman
pis si facebook c'est honteux rappeur
pas bon c'est sa maman mais je pense que
c'est ça aussi la suite communauté qu'on
a tous besoin la recherche de saint picq
il est très important que ce soit la
religion catholique ce soit n'importe
quoi il lui manque toujours besoin de
ces paires d'yeux les questions like
qu'elle soit notifications facebook
instagram cela comporte un instantané ça
stimule la même hormone quelqu'un du bon
à vrai dire je ne savais rien et que
c'est juste que ça sur la mémoire
sorbonne mais genre 0 1% de sa bourse
aux vélos
c'est comme dans la vraie vie d'en
savourer comme j'ai rencontré j'ai eu
mon besoin social c'est comme manger on
aurait beau avoir des liens sociaux
c'est dans maintenant on est un animal
social donne un petit air de plus
facebook c'est surfait ont engagé des
ingénieurs de jeux casino pour avoir les
notifications puis lice les systèmes de
gamification les plus efficaces
possibles pour qu'on passe le plus de
temps possible devant l'écran
qu'est-ce vous passerez donc les
machines sont construites pour qui on a
envie de départ substantielles à 2 peu
juste mais tant le bruit indications une
crise qui est inquiétant des ding texto
savoir donner enfin de moi ça fait
l'effet de wallace en lui même si le
terrain d'un autre les digues de
chercher par la police
sympa parce qu'il fallait que quelqu'un
qui me disait tu oublié d'effacer toute
trace et le téléphone
un appel aux ailes et c'est grave non
mais ça c'est juste des arts dont le nom
mais si voyons gti turris efron qui
m'appelle je réponds oui c'est un numéro
inconnu g réponse intéressant publie
chez vous c'est que j'oublie de court
séjour trois parties vont lancer un
message assez pop il a six mois après
j'en ai commandé autant nous on a vu un
problème de relations publiques puis je
vais prendre un détail mais à chaque
fois pendant comme deux trois jours
après le achaque fois que mon cellulaire
il y avait quoi que ce soit là j'avais
gens qui apprécient comme ses marques
[Musique]
paypal et de l'hormone que ce sacre est
le montant d assez crétin et style parlé
pendant 2h12 met face à face on est on
est pas de téléphone en fait juste
discuter entre êtres humains aient pitié
ou six parce que pendant des générations
des générations les humains ont fait
surtout dans le feu de se raconter
d'histoires de feu la télévision est
venue comme remplacer sont un peu parce
que c'est une source lumineuse et qui
raconte des histoires mais pile et
l'internet c'est encore plus pernicieux
parce que c'était encore plus proche de
tous au début c'est le fun c'est pour
tout le monde du moins la télé en
faisant peut plus séparer les écrans y
avait quand même un constat que ce
rendez vous avec ma famille au complet
n'en jouit d'un salon le com comme un
auto infos filmant sa part
peut-être trouvé le moyen de reims taris
et malté pige pas je pense pas que la
solution c'est la télé dans sa balle au
moins d'être développé des moments comme
celui des maisons dans nos appartements
est ensemble
j'ai remis aujourd'hui où ça s'appelait
un cambre 610 c'est jusqu'à quatre sauts
faut qu'ils se fassent que clairement
pour rentrer dedans il faut coller les
chauffer quand même ça même plus beau
c'est vraiment joli mais la police et
qui a porté les milieux j'avais deux
fois en phase aller et dans le temps les
fouilles ont fait des soeurs on les
colle et de faire avec nos amis nos
collègues nos familles c'est un besoin
primaire que facebook et c'est de
remplacer mais c'est pas mal plus simple
la fin comme bio conférence parce que
comme ça mais quand ça fait juste
rentrer la tv ça va dans un sens mais
toudic sort comme les pâtes et facultés
d de paroles des chansons comme des fous
il ya des moments où louis it et après
certains y étaient plus capable de
communiquer par mois cette année est
vraiment fort sur la barre à blanc c'est
je pense ce genre dé 12 ans la blonde
elle y en a qui s'appelle liana bureau
surtout si ça va sortir bientôt premier
single en janvier à woippy
e
je pense et je pensais des journées
devant leur usine et ont voté à réaliser
puis m6 qui le met en avant une place le
soir tard j'étais tellement gens
connectés je parlais du monde j'y vais
vous inquiéter et quand tu es vraiment
comme les liens sociaux le puits mugenzi
nos choses c'est au cégep est passé
vraiment beaucoup trop de temps à
pratiquer la guide c'est beau la vie
mais tu vois les autres depuis mes temps
quand on commence à faire des podcasts
ça m'aide beaucoup parce que moi c'est
juste avant de rentrer à audi n'allait
pas cgt à la maîtrise en littérature
cinéma fait qu'une fois par semaine les
aliments de 2e 3e c'est quoi ce qu'on
parlait de ces genres des conversations
qui y mode qui stimule en est-il utile
au club pas trois mois ben ali a regardé
les champs de riz sans rien dire pendant
deux jours de sucre aux épices passait
rien pas d'activités dont le cerveau est
chaude donc complètement puis ça m'a
pris jusqu'à y at il eu ça fait c'est
quoi ça fait 19 pas de casque ont fait
une vingtaine de paca stop puis depuis
20 depuis 20 semaines mettons là c'est
là que ça recommence et tt accélère
n'est pas capable de parler je te promet
d'amener un point à bon port ce n'est
pas capable d'exprimer mon opinion d'
exprimer mais est-ce que ce que je
ressentais comme du monde
effectivement j'avais les boules avant
l'évolution chez moi chez toi aussi tu
es comme ça fait dix ans que je fais ça
on sait lui oui
c'est jean jacques je parle beaucoup
mais je pense beaucoup si je fais les
deux épis
c'est la mission que je me donne d'un
quart d'heure contenu décidé d'aller
chercher des choses en moi pis dans le
monde c'est de les synthétiser pour les
données mais aussi le dire et c'est long
c'est comme cela c'est un méga projet
s'exprimer peu réfléchi mais le contexte
d'un direct et certain d'être au live
pour moi c'est comme j'ai fait j'ai fait
3 1 de réseau communautaire bénévole
avec live deux heures par semaine pour
zéro dollar pourrait payer le jour j le
direct est un must liquide si nous
regardons je fasse plus tard voilà télé
communautaire par une chaîne youtube par
un podcast même s'il s'est passé je te
regarde et moi j'ai commencé à passer
dans mon char t ah ouais je fais juste
ce n'est pas juste un magazine un
magazine je fais ta place après des
mauvais mais aussi pour procès sont
réclamées temps j'écoute a pas de casse
to which j'écoutais la radio en chantier
montréal tout le temps avec gilts à plat
après une charge la ferme
pilote mais je consens traité comme est
en train de faire une activité intense
cérébrale concentré je vais pas réfléchi
today qui logiquement saab et plus juste
réfléchir sur la voix haute comme seules
quatre valeurs 10 as tu as son podcast
fait l'effort de l'exprimer synthétisant
tentait depuis ça vraiment justement
explique l'armée parce que tu exprimes
une pensée ou expriment une dit que
jamais sortie av a sorti un petit peu
floue bien s'énonce clairement
je veux qu'ils aient sciemment comprend
bien les choses et s'exprimer les
maudits ce qui se comprend bien ce dont
j'ai envie c'est plus amélie htc comme
la guinée comme l'a dit un niveau que
j'ai jamais vu ça
non mais le chapeau parfois qui dirait
jamais ils touchent pas très peu
caméléon revers satinés que les
caméléons à sa façon de faire autant il
était excellent au début sans dire est
qu au temps a fait du bruit c'est pas la
même personne ne sait vraiment quand on
avait fait une collab avec lui ouais
vraiment content du tout à des questions
maintenant la tonne qui fait le plus
rire la tonne que je réfléchisse chanson
que de nomi sega le 6e puis en plus d'un
mélomane incroyable chercher les points
mais c'est en même temps oui qui a fait
pas mal de quebecor mai puis vraie
histoire mais c'est factuel répétées de
travailler à vous excuser un temps
pluvieux recherché qui savent ont été
confirmés dans le fond
les codes décote d'abidjan le chercher
la semaine était plus basse que les
attentes sont à chercher un consultant
qui avait déjà trouvé sur love story est
un expert en bsb qui est pour reprendre
les mots de jay du temps mais mais bref
essai en bsb qui a dit le problème dans
votre show ce que tout le monde sait
c'est qui qui sont vraiment là pour
avoir un job puis qui ont une chance en
communication puisque vu que c'est
évident et aucune intrigue
donc vous devez brasser s'appuie en
lever un des meilleurs puis il y en a
qui ont truqué le vote pour que ce soit
moins compte ni causé semaine le parce
qu'on revient sur le vote public en mode
on s'en fou qui gang de ce pas sombrer
comme la personne la personne qui est
compétent d'envol l'avion demander aux
gens sur place de voter pour qui partent
en une copie mois alors que le public y
avait des manoeuvres en vue en mode jean
musée pelouse de talent je remettais pas
d'entrée ni compter mais mais mais
nico est en partie j'ai pleuré cet
épisode le puits apprécié j'ai gagné
toutes les banques publiques noté de les
semaines pour deux raisons 1 g plus
grand nombre pi 2 classique la glace et
u2 avant lui qu'à diviser le vote de
l'uqam aucune course les deux hommes
venaient de l'uqam avoir fait penser que
c'est nico qui participent à ces bon
alors c'est quoi la voie de bro lui
parce qu'il était vraiment meilleur que
moi sur scène des histoires parce que
c'est le pulse et les frais partition
parce que ce n'est pas les libérer
les conséquences de ces les compétiteurs
qui eux lyon ils m'ont ils dit bonnes
âmes à face lors désole un copain à
quatre afin que stratégique de jeu que
les boîtes d'intervalle des sites qui je
me mettais tout est blanc comme qui
gagnent tant qu'homme je sais pas trop
mais
et je la cherchais pro materi a peur
[Musique]
de quoi c'est comme si plus fiables je
parlais de matrice à l'époque était le
chercher ça se joue la tb connaissait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup la
télévision top pourtant d'amour ça sera
connaissait bien la télévision savez
animer et tu dis là dedans alors que moi
je connaissais la musique toute la com
que la presse a appris là dessus exact
c'est comme moi je suis tout à fait
juste est plus facile de chercher
contenant quel contenu ce que je
travaille d'accord mais pas libres
jamais un bon du coup envie si j'étais
moins orienté vers ça mais moi je trouve
que c'est plus facile d'apprendre la
technique
merci commence par l'ex caennais se
promener ménégon qu'il met mais moi j'ai
pas technique mais non mais tu lis
beaucoup bits soit chercher des vrais à
terrebonne quelqu'un se fait pas tout
fois ta caméra un monde ouvrages des
quatre codes urbains
évidemment la gare message l'histoire de
la finance était curieuse lors de la
finale il restait qu'à l'invitation pour
le voyez - pillon n'était au courant de
rien mais au bloc juste avant le
dévoilement du gagnant et on dit alors
dit avec toi exo il dit en passant mais
car l'artiste elle s'est choisi de quoi
c'est la joie ni de cette émission le
spi c'est correct parce qu'il l'assumé
pleinement
quand même à lui l'église jeu de
télé-réalité pml et love story de ce
monde sort alors que moi j'étais
clairement dans notre budget de 3 mois
sandjak le tpf active le côté de leur
acte et je m'en servais mon avantage
mais comme
dès qu ils avaient dû jouer à marrakech
justement de pouvoir regarder les
épisodes à chaque semaine entre de toi
même continué d'état manioc sicav un
comité j'avais deux mes amis de l'uqam
déjà extrêmement personnel qui travaille
dans l'industrie qui comme on écoute moi
j'ai peut-être jamais j'écoutais la
saison nous donnant à penser avec toupet
ash 95 et honda c'est le seul droit a
dit que rien ne m'est donc passer le
budget les chercher on s'assoit y est
ils ont analysé et après deux semaines
on était comme parfait continue et cette
chère que je t'aime favori de la preuve
je passe plus de temps au début tout le
temps que tu est le favori mais j'ai vu
qu'un ces deux mutations
j'ai vu le moment chez comme je pus
favorise la fraude pays comme ben tu
vois les émissions si ça change la
guerre
on a vu ce moment le décrit le moment où
est ce qu était le favori mais les
atouts est ce que tu es tu on l'a vu
exactement émission beckham et engendrer
un sketch j'ai pris un sketch où est-ce
que chez le roi php au couteau parce que
c'est trop c'est trop facile d'être
casté puis c'était trop facile apprécié
de force
le clac b206 coma qui gagnent en réalité
des fragments quelqu'un je suppose
qu'elle est moi je pense que c'est la
même chose pour but de rechercher le
plus important c'est le show mais après
ce aurait donc passionnant à meknès
pleinement sa place en tant que miroir
pis mais juste la maca non sa victoire
et on dit en passant le deuxième prix
comme piste est prévue vers le bas si tu
vas être mojo band journalistes ce que
j'ai su après c'est que celle du web
mathieu les à l'époque que te rencontrer
la semaine passée était directeur
mathieu on est allé au-delà de ce loto
puis moi ça bientôt en cash par 7 août à
qui s'appelait marc la playmate mais je
pense à tout acte est marqué ce que j'ai
appris à l'époque c'est quid j'ai besoin
d'un jeune cube d'un jeune louise qui
veut comme qui hors ligne puis ils m'ont
donc offert un job à temps partiel
c'était excellent parce que c'est parce
que tatiana la jav à temps plein jour au
lendemain pis
et puis pour vrai c'est beaucoup plus
une job d'animatrice télé comme auch
j'aurais eu de la neige avait beaucoup
plus à apprendre sur ce niveau le ch je
suis le web est aujourd'hui cela mais si
je serai mieux ou moins bien mais dans
tous les coachs hills après quand j'ai
l'impression de serait moins bien parce
que tu serais pas aussi versatile que
tous les journalistes aucun des gros
clubs on en abuse et 24/24 ça c'est
après fait sa salle a un impact beaucoup
sur la housse qui compta labro vécu
parce que sinon j'aurais po comme l'ong
stone viola tube c'est comme ça de ma
dépression mais le staff comme j'ai
l'habitude à seedorf
c'était du temps de déplacement
professionnel slash maladie mentale mais
j'en parle de long en large dans une
vidéo que j'ai déjà fait au calme qui
est sur ma machine j'accorde un peu
comme le plus grand fort philippe
d'assister enfin clairement m il savait
pas non plus moi les jeux savez pour
nous ici non je savais mais il n'avait
pas encore parlé
il n'y en avait pas il y avait promis
des monstres risques je suis avec
véhicule je le voyais que je savais le i
ce cachet pour lui c'est justement
parlait pas je t'ai pas dit que tu étais
passé
connaissant pas
parce que moi j'étais super chanceux
d'avoir été repris par le stand santé
publique et glaciaux québec d'avoir
écouté les conseils
d'abord écouté l'ellipse car depuis les
as goûté la peur qui choisit qui m'ont
aidé puis bref souvent ce qui se passe
dans ma vie je suis vraiment content de
l'avoir vécu sans jo comme à me décaler
cinq ans quand j'y pense mais comme ça
m'a tellement
amener de l'empathie fille de la
réflexion sur ces enjeux qui sont
complètement essentiel au disco ou bien
actuelle je suis loin d'être cela il
pense par le juste aujourd'hui j'ai vu
claude bégin dans la convention il ya un
groupe starwood il a donné rennes et est
appuyé par la dépression puis par le
parti wafd continuons de la fois je me
demande maintenant l'aide jusqu'à
acheter pour 30 ans combien de gens ont
bien d'autres vraiment beaucoup ce que
j'avançais radio can say climatiques
sont vraiment sous la porte et met un
baume et oui c'est qu'ils sont encore
jeunes fois puisque je joue le tour de
trop par jo thério et fous je m'organise
vont jamais avec des amis enfin bref
mais les idées de la santé mentale plus
tournant j'ai écouté mais algo puis
chansons d'amour ça me santé publique au
québec paient donc a les yeux et les
sens de crise ça s'appelle le sang un
centre de crise
son feuillage à montréal certainement
exact sinon il ya plein doute beaucoup
plus tôt et aux noms d'îles en deux
branches qui s'occupe de ce mets puis ça
s'appelle la première chose à faire
c'était vraiment dépenser 2 mai
encore en pointe partout par exemple
plusieurs endroits dont il manque d'eau
il faut que tu ailles fait une tentative
à 20 monsieur legault important pour
vous puis on parle ne fait aucun doute
les vidéos est en dessous des travaux
sinon écoutez vous qui parlez en au
moins deux personnes avaient à dire
qu'il faut tout dire si cette personne
ne se posera plus après un psychologue
c'est vraiment vraiment gens qui sont
comme gênés ou embarrassé par effet
longtemps je pense pige à 0 idée
d'équité deux sites
c'est saint piat ce c'est pas mal mieux
que d'aller au botteur botul c'est quoi
ce n'est pas le cas ça ferme et chez moi
[Musique]
mais les secousses y pique un peu sur le
pays s'est calé d'accord mais supprimons
là je suis en santé mentale aussi avec
les couleurs des psys
sèmassi par notts county problème mais
tellement besoin criant d'avoir une
écoute attentive qui est beaucoup de
gens qui vont avoir comme seul arrêt
brusque attentive mais aussi sans
jugement il ya déjà mais au final avec
mais moi je ferai comme les
travailleuses du sexe qui qui sont très
vocal sur internet il parle beaucoup de
ce que souvent c'est la première ligne
de psychologie parce que quelqu un joli
petit il s'est comme souvent c'est la
personne à qui vont tout confie surtout
s'ils ont des problèmes familiaux avec
la femme couette
donc est ce notre exemple et ce après
plus de riz dans notre société il faut
que le travail du sexe est légal ou ccc
cameroun qui est sympa mais je suis bien
d'accord
comme à mon facebook que je peux te
proposer 24 féministe oui je me dis
c'est le par des femmes avaient dit oui
pour la vidéo ou au début de l'automne
que la presse
après ce genre après +7 je voulais faire
venga ses 20 ans sa bosse depuis passé
ça comme on veut
la ville est à voulait faire un gang
bang bang bang bang restaient présentes
elles avaient choqué regardez puisqu'à
ce jour les règles sont gardés par mois
mais c'est un bon gars on va tout à voir
l'histoire
j'aimerais vraiment je vais écouter
cette vidéo là avec lui on est comme on
sait comme suivie sur twitter dans le
moment où je suis passé dans mon
augmentation mammaire parce qu'elle est
rendue juge avoir ça continue pour
double 10e double double des bleus
chose qu'on n'a pas sur la chaîne nbc
je me suis vie à cause que je partageais
mais mon histoire pillet était là dedans
aussi pierre en fait ça c'est vraiment
ce que je pense que ben jawad est mal
passé non allez en parler des temps des
fêtes
sorti dès le 1er janvier 2019
qui est jean rougeau temps vous souhaite
quoi mais tant qu'à côté des faits quand
vous suspense tant d'autres qu'est ce
qu'on vous souhaite plus je fais moi moi
à chaque fois que j'ai quelque chose à
souhaiter que ce soit jean sédatif le
bon endroit
l'album de tableau d'un bref point l
album mais c'est goa c'est quoi sa
tomate en moyenne 5 go qui tourne à
radio déjà je sais pas si vraiment la
musique et en anglais c'est plutôt pour
les radios québec ne sais pas si ça a
marché
sa pensée parce que ça peut pas je sais
on a vraiment travaillé fort cet album
le jeu
l'objectif c'est que 2010 soit l'année
du premier tour n'ont commencé à la
brenda et son nom liana bureau
excellent c'est juste liana bureau c com
- ouais passe-passe marketing le te fait
te conduis mais n'est ce pas ce qu'on
dit c'est quoi son nom foot se répondent
et en ligne
la prochaine génération découvrez-la
l'accord n'ont jusqu'à l'hôtel ariana
les sensations mais on est prêt pour
toile y en a mais seulement sur le nom
parce que tout le monde
rihanna sait course officieuse google
les analyses sanguines et prometteur et
qui par là dedans viennent quelque chose
que vous allez retourner plus de 10
c'est le plus beau mais quand green day
démonter la montagne c'est le plus
difficile mais qu'est-ce qu'on soit en
double
on souhaite de retrouver à 100% les
péages d'amendé déjà tu peux venir
les olympiques la santé mentale ses
occupations de places est un jeu
ces soldats devaient d'émotionnel mais
c'est tellement pesante et comme c'est
littéralement mais du monde en cage puis
voir comment ils réagissent quand la
jeune fille pendant une capsule herman
cache pendant ces jours ci comme ça mais
dans quoi ils s'embarquent n'ont jamais
su et maintenant je suis sûr qu'ils
rencontrent ma blonde ça fausse le delà
de ce que je leur ai malgré tout pas
fait quoi je parlais à tibet là je sais
pas si on va la rencontrer à 20 mais on
veut faire en pâtir c'est catherine qui
a gagné cette année encore je les ai
rencontrés
notre part t2 d'agencés venu parce que
c'est mon avis la liste pendant la même
agence
puis dans le fond qu'à quitter aller les
seules personnes qui avaient fait au
deccan insistait à l'anis et lp qui sont
partis tout artiste proférant elle plus
personne quand elle est rentrée j'ai
fait le feedback qu'elle a eues ces
appels c'est une bonne expérience
le g10 est ce parce que vous y pensez
finit pas de gamme audi
c
je leur ferai pas non plus elle a gagné
puis moi moi ce que je disais c'est à
partir de là plus à voir tomber
oui oui c'est sûr que oui mais il ya
juste deux personnes qui l'ont
la maison tu y ailles attachants les
hommes à partir la semaine six mois des
meilleurs aude qu'à la lotto deux pièces
de même pour la tribune tout parce que
chaque fois s'il vous plaît sur ce merci
d'avoir été le bond de 26 ans merci
grand merci grand merci aux parents les
témoins quatre ans soit en bas dans les
ippj et harry
[Musique]